antes de ver en detalle las otras
gráficas del libro veamos lo que thomas
piketty establece como teorías del por
qué tenemos este incremento en
desigualdad en el ingreso de eeuu
una teoría es que esto es ocasionado por
la mano de obra y en particular tenemos
este fenómeno de los altos ejecutivos
altos ejecutivos en las grandes
corporaciones que están recibiendo
ingresos cada vez mayores o sea tiene
una mayor
participación
el ingreso
esto puede darse por dos razones o quizá
alguna combinación de estas una es que
el mercado quizá está reconociendo la
importancia de tener altos ejecutivos
por lo que en las últimas décadas se
nota que les están pagando cada vez más
a estas personas ya que éstas
administran corporaciones cada vez más
grandes y si ellas son capaces de
obtener un rendimiento de capital del 2%
o 3% mayor de una empresa
multimillonaria o hacen que aumente el
crecimiento de ésta pues quizás valga la
pena pagarle estos grandes sueldos a
estas personas o darles una mayor
participación del ingreso así que una
posibilidad es que el mercado reconoce
el valor
pero otra cosa que la autor cita y que
es lo que él cree que es lo más probable
es que durante las últimas décadas los
altos ejecutivos han podido controlar lo
que ellos mismos reciben como
compensación es esto es lo que el autor
piensa que ha estado pasando una auto
regulación
del ingreso y muchas personas que se
autorregulan el ingreso tienen
aumentárselo o es posible que se tenga
una combinación de ambas teorías ésta es
una dinámica que el autor argumenta es
la que ocasiona el aumento en la
desigualdad el que los altos ejecutivos
tienen cada vez una mayor participación
en el ingreso la otra razón es
ocasionada por el capital
y tal y se basa en la idea de que el
rendimiento del capital r
es mayor que el crecimiento entonces
durante generaciones aquellos que tienen
capital en especial aquellos que generan
una participación desproporcionada de
este ingreso del capital
su riqueza proporcional crecerá a una
participación cada vez mayor de la
economía a qué me refiero con esto bueno
si la mayoría de tu ingreso viene de tu
mano de obra entonces tu salario se
basara en las fuerzas del mercado de
cuánto más valor se puede agregar a una
organización o de cuántas personas
tienen cierta habilidad o de cómo puedes
negociar el apalancamiento y todo este
tipo de cosas pero si la mayor parte de
tu ingreso no viene de la mano de obra
sino del rendimiento del capital a qué
me refiero con esto digamos que tú eres
su doctor
y recibes 200 mil dólares al año
y este va a ser tu ingreso por mano de
obra
ingreso por mano de obra
pero imaginemos que ha recibido una
herencia de 10 millones de dólares la
cual has invertido y recibes una
ganancia o rendimiento de capital del 5%
así que está r es igual al 5% el 5% de
10 millones es 500 mil dólares anuales
esto es el ingreso por capital
ingreso por capital el argumento del
autor es que una vez que se llega a
cierto punto y comienzas a tener mucho
capital y el rendimiento es mayor que el
crecimiento de la economía si vemos el
ejemplo del doctor que va de 10 millones
a 10.5 millones en un año el cual crece
otro 5% cada año y va a estar creciendo
más rápido que la economía pues el
doctor podría dejarle esto a sus hijos o
alguien más y ellos podrían continuar
invirtiendo de la misma manera de tal
forma que con el paso del tiempo se
tenga una riqueza digna de una dinastía
de manera que tus herederos ya no
necesitan trabajar para vivir este
fenómeno por sí solo en el que tú eres
das dinero lo inviertes y obtienes un
rendimiento que crees más rápido que la
economía con el paso del tiempo pues se
tendrá una participación cada vez más
grande de la economía voy a hacer una
hoja de cálculo para mostrarles esta
dinámica en otros vídeos el autor
también apunta que pueden haber otras
dinámicas que equilibren
esta es una de las dinámicas que apoya
la mano de obra y vemos algunos ejemplos
en los que estrellas del deporte o los
mejores administradores de fondo de
cobertura tienen una participación
desproporcionada del ingreso quizá parte
de esto esté justificado o quizá no
alcanzamos estos rendimientos por lo que
algo de nuestros ingresos tienen que
venir de la mano de obra pero también
puede ocurrir lo contrario que las
personas reciban un ingreso enorme por
mano de obra el cual les permite a ellos
oa las personas que reciben este dinero
para estar a esta categoría de aquí
donde una participación desproporcionada
del ingreso sea del rendimiento del
capital en lugar de su mano de obra y
esto nos lleva a la idea de que
tendremos una mayor tasa de ahorro si se
tiene un mayor ingreso por ejemplo
digamos que hay dos personas la persona
y la persona a ver digamos que la
persona a gana
en mil dólares al año y la persona ve
gana un millón de dólares al año este es
su ingreso y aún no sabemos de dónde
viene si de la mano de obra o del
rendimiento de capital este es solamente
su ingreso anual la persona se considera
de clase media alta quizás tenga una
hipoteca o pago de su casa por lo que
sus gastos anuales son ochenta mil
dólares y digamos que los ingresos son
después de impuestos y aquí lo escribo
ingresos después de impuestos los gastos
son de 80 mil al año por lo que le
quedarán como ahorros
veinte mil dólares anuales mientras que
la persona ve tiene un millón de dólares
después de impuestos cada año por lo que
puede vivir de una manera digamos que
más de la morosa es probable que tenga
más gastos imaginemos que ambos tienen
una familia del mismo tamaño pero la
persona ve gasta cinco veces más que la
persona a el psir gasta 400 mil dólares
anuales
así pues su ahorro será de 600 mil
dólares pueden ver que la persona tiene
una tasa de ahorro del 20 por ciento de
su ingreso después de impuestos de los
100.000 mientras que la persona ve tiene
un ahorro del 60 por ciento aunque es
perfectamente posible que la persona ve
derroche el dinero y hasta el 80 por
ciento de su ingreso tendremos este
fenómeno de que mientras más grande sea
esto va a ser más difícil gastarse lo
todo puede imaginarse a alguien con un
menor ingreso de 40 mil o 50 mil tendrá
que gastar todo su ingreso y no podrá
ahorrar nada así que mientras el ingreso
después de impuestos se haga cada vez
más grande comparado con el costo nivel
de vida estándar la tasa de ahorro
generalmente va a crecer mientras más
aumente la tasa de ahorro nos
acercaremos cada vez más a esta
categoría en donde se beneficiará más
del rendimiento del capital en donde
éste crece más rápido que la economía
otra pregunta que nos podemos hacer es
ver cuánto tiempo puede durar esto
nuevamente mi objetivo es articular lo
que sucede en este libro el cual tienen
que leer con mente abierta y crítica
esto tiene sentido cuáles son los
factores de equilibrio y bueno esto no
puede durar toda la vida porque esto no
puede continuar para siempre